benvenuti ad una nuova partita di
hammond questa volta tu giocherai con
noi e una partita e interattiva
deciderai tu cosa fare durante il gioco
appariranno varie castellini e tu dovrai
scegliere il quale casellina cliccare
per continuare dovrei scoprire chi è
l'impostore ma stai attento a non essere
eliminato l'unica regola di questo gioco
e di non fare spoiler nei commenti non
scrivere nei commenti chieli impostore
dopo aver finito il gioco puoi ritrovare
tutte le volte che vuoi server di gioco
pur iniziare da capo d'acqua e provare
con altre scelte lascia un bel mi piace
se questo video raggiunge i 20 mila mi
piace ci sarà un secondo video
interattivo among us in cui potrai
scegliere tutte e tre un impostore o un
fiume sarà super divertente che unisce
gli scrivilo giù nei commenti e ti dico
fate iniziamo la nostra partita
[Musica]
ma in quanti siamo nella navicella oggi
più mezza l'accordo fra da giallo ok
iniziamo con la prima scelta dovrai
decidere tu cosa andremo a fare quindi
cosa scegli tra queste due opzioni se
gli una delle due caselline e ti
porteranno ognuna in una strada diversa
quale scegli
[Musica]